the orioles saw him in washington he
would not get a decision he gave up the
grand slam the mount castle but he gave
up six runs and five of them earlier
high drive from trey mancini on the
first page to left center goodbye a home
run for mancini
in the first inning against leicester
the orioles strike again yeah a lot of
people on their feet celebrating
not only the home run the fact he's
playing
so there's his 17th home of the year his
first since the derby well he's been
driving the ball if you pitch him away
to right if you come in i mean this is
when you know your swing is good you
just react matt harvey yeah trying to
make it two wins in a row those are the
numbers the era well not where he wants
it to be
and that's another one yeah and he hits
the corner
yeah he's he's tightening his gloves
because he thinks he's gonna hit again
take a look how far he has to move the
club
stevenson goes down swinging 95 high and
titan it's three perfect innings in the
books for matt harvey this is the left
fielder ryan mckenna
well hit left side and harrison
reacting at the hot corner and then bell
getting his feet and his legs out of the
way
of the oncoming basement yeah it's been
the hot corner too line drive off the
bat of pedro severino last eddie and now
he gets the hot shot off the battle ryan
mckenna not a problem he's playing in
for the bun i always felt like third was
a little bit easier the shallower you
played so if you trey mancini hit a
cutter in for a home run where are you
looking here maybe away
he'll pull it again harrison
time
yes sir
josh harrison sparkling at third base
tonight laying out i think getting up as
quick as he did was a difference there
ryan mount castle with two down
mount castle to drive to center field
this one's got a shot at the wall and
gone
ryan mount castle does in john lester
for the second time this season the
orioles second long ball tonight so home
run number 16 gives the orioles a
two-nothing lead
tremendous power
uris the shortstop
got a pitch up another defensive gem
escobar this time well they got a solo
homer and some defense behind john
lester kept it from being a possible
beginning for the organs they're gonna
have to get three runs to take the lead
and there's a really nice pitch there
three strikeouts tonight for harvey
another ground ball marias will take
this one late decision in front of aleka
and it's five innings
one hit
no runs for matt harvey
[Applause]
to his left escobar
the nets have some web gems on the
infield tonight two by him and a couple
by harrison 74 pitches
sunday at kansas city this will be
number 74 here with one out in the sixth
inning for matt harvey
and stevenson down swinging for the
second time fourth strikeout again a
young hitter fastball hitter you make
the pitch it's all about getting ahead
to the right side in mancini
it's a six-inning shutout performance
for matt harvey for the second straight
start
what a second half for matt
[Applause]
one to right field this is a bear ball
into the corner to score cedric
and for the second straight night cedric
mullins doubles austin hayes follows by
doubling him in
the two best friends forever make it
three nothing so you missed with a
curveball
what are you looking for
a fast ball at least you can you know
you can take a shot at it because you're
ahead in the count shorter runs it down
hayes very much like
mullins thinking triple until he goes
and gets it in the corner
indolent field base hits city
hits so hard it'll only score one
but the orioles will gladly take that
one austin hayes in pedro severino
drives him home
rbi for severino for the second straight
night and he always had another in the
sixth
i mean it's as you mentioned so hard
that
mara really makes a nice shot coming in
i mean he short hops this ball usually
that gets by
everybody's going to score
already two runs here in the sixth 13
rbis last 16 for sevy now michael pronco
that balls to right center juan soto is
gonna get there a great play by soto
but trey mancini tags and scores
really nice sacrifice fly yeah i mean
all the way around you know good at back
good defense and right by soto
mancini trey goes right back goes right
back and tags up didn't go halfway you
know he knows he's going to score if the
ball gets by him that's what we were
talking about soto
excellent outfielder everybody talks
about his back
soto the other way how well did he hit
it
c
u
later
and finally tonight the nats are on the
board sono number 17. that's what i'm
talking about nice adjustment juan soto
17th home run going the other way a
majestic drive to left center gets the
nats on the board nice swing
off speed let it travel and maybe one of
the first pitches he's seen in a while
out over the plate they've been crowding
him with off speed in and fastballs in
it's up to train
and ants have two hits tonight three
actually
trey a double back in the fourth
and
right center to score a couple
key boom following
harrison holm
5-3 ball game got a hanging slider there
that's the first one he's really left up
in the zone the rest have been in the
dirt foot down early trey with a two
strike approach there
on the first pitch maybe because
scott's out of the stretch and he didn't
want to time the leg kick and now you'll
have to deal with soto who the last time
he came up hit his 17th home run to the
opposite field
high pop up from soto
mask is off for severino tossed his side
balls secured and the inning over
two in but two left behind
and the orioles will carry a lead into
the bottom of the end been a long time
since
31 000 fans have felt this loud at
oriole park
strike three in the orioles win it dylan
tate shuts the door
with a scoreless ninth
and the orioles have taken the first two
from the gnats
in front of the biggest crowd in two
years at oriole park